[Music]  the apartment complex that was once  missing stairs appears to have stairs  once again but they cannot be used  february 14th the stairs were knocked  off the building on washington near  bruce  when a car crashed right into them  tenants were actually using a ladder and  a chain to get up and down the city of  vegas sent out  an inspector today and we found out the  stairs are not up to code  the contractor will have to fix the  areas that were not up to code  including guard rails being incorrectly  installed inspectors will return  once again and once those changes are  made denise  it's been a long road for those tenants  well